[Music]
we have an amazing resource here nate is
truly one of our great authorities on
the election system on campaign
financing all kinds of matters of our
democracy and I suspect that many of us
in this room have a lot of questions
about our democracy broadly this year so
one thing you should know is that he is
right now under deadline as the special
master of the redistricting process for
North Carolina he's drawing fair
districts for them something he's done
for four or five different states over
the years and so we may be risking
democracy in another part of the country
by him sneaking out to talk to us
tonight and we're really appreciative of
that and so you know we really do think
about the some questions both on this
topic and some of those related ones
around district redistricting and so
forth
so that we can really have a great Q&A
session after this because we're gonna
have a lot of time to I think we'll all
enjoy that and with that I think nothing
more to do but please give a big round
of applause for tonight's guest speaker
Nate personally please apropos of my new
role as Special Master that is the
before photo this is the after okay it
is the most exhausting thing that I do
as my first of all thank you all for
coming thank you Michael for the
invitation thank you everyone here for
putting this on I'm a law professor of
political scientists and a lawyer I
often say that you can tell what I'm a
law professor because I have opinions
without data you can tell when I'm a
political scientist because I have data
without opinions and you know what I'm a
lawyer well it depends what my client
wants me to say so
I'm gonna I'm gonna shift between those
two those sort of three personalities in
talking about this question of can
democracy survive the Internet
I also sometimes say that as a scholar
of the law of democracy there's a sense
in which my job is a little bit like an
anthropologist studying human
cannibalism which is that you have to
replace normal human impulses of disgust
and revulsion and replace them with
fascination and curiosity and so that to
some extent a whether you're doing
redistricting or dealing with the voting
technology or campaign finance reform
consider it a coping mechanism so so
I'll talk a little bit about some of
those other areas in maybe the qat
but I want to specifically talk today
about my current research and and sort
of what I've been trying to do at
Stanford dealing with the effect of the
internet on democracy so let me tell you
how I got into this because I'm not
naturally a techy even though I you know
am at Stanford and it's sort of in the
bloodstream there the one of my areas of
expertise as Michael said is is campaign
finance and so when the Citizens United
case came down a few years ago most
people looked at that case and said this
is a case about corporations being given
individual rights right you know
corporations are people in like if you
remember that case was about how
corporations did they have the First
Amendment right to spend unlimited
amounts of money on advertising right
and the Supreme Court said that they did
advertising with respect to campaigns
the case itself though really wasn't
about corporate advertising it was about
a movie that was put up on demand by
this nonprofit corporation called
Citizens United
sort of like HBO on demand or any of the
other Xfinity on demand or I don't know
what dish on demand I don't want to be
prejudiced here so so then the and so
the question in that case was whether
this movie that you could download right
off of this on-demand platform
was protected by the First Amendment or
could the government essentially ban a
corporation in this case a non-profit
corporation from spending corporate
funds on a movie because it was a
hatchet job against Hillary Clinton okay
and like I said most people looked at
that as a First Amendment case and what
is this all about
corporations having personal free speech
rights I looked at that case and I said
you know what this is really about is
the future of sort of changing
telecommunication and politics what
happens when we move from linear
programming television ads sort of like
the 30-second ads that have been the
kind of coin of the realm when it comes
to political advertising
one of them's we moved from that world
into a world of on-demand programming
where so much of the political
communication is happening principally
through the internet okay and all of our
sort of campaign finance architecture
and jurisprudence is predicated on a
world where it's television which is the
main motive of political communication
in fact in the case itself in citizens
united there was actually an interesting
colloquy between Justice Kennedy and the
Solicitor General where he asked him at
one point he says so if you can ban a
movie if you can if you can this
on-demand movie that sit-ins unite is
trying to put up online if you can say
that a corporation can't put that up can
you been a book right because hey if you
can ban one thing you can ban the other
right if a corporation doesn't have
these speaker a speaker speaker rights
they shouldn't be able to put up a book
either he says well this is in the
responses now this isn't the case about
this this is you know it's about
television advertising it says well wait
a second are you saying that the First
Amendment theory the government allows
the government to ban a corporate
sponsored book and he tries to evade the
question again and then he comes in and
Justice Kennedy says hey what about that
new Kindle thing it literally says that
new Kindle thing it says that's not
that's kind of like a satellite
communication isn't it because you beam
a book down onto your laptop or whatever
a Kindle device right could the
government ban that kind of satellite
communication and and again the lawyer
kind of
vacillates and and tries to get around
it and then Chief Justice Roberts sort
of like puts his hand on the table says
what's the answer if is it consistent
with the government's theory that you
would be able to ban a book if the
corporation uses its Treasury funds in
order to fund it and then the Surgeon
General says yes and then there was an
audible intake of air in the classroom
in in the courtroom and so when I teach
my students the First Amendment class I
often say if you learn nothing else
during this semester don't be on the
side of book banning when you're arguing
for the Supreme Court you know and that
case is what led to the court striking
and that scenario led to the courts
striking down the mccain-feingold law
that was at issue in Citizens United as
I said for me it really posed the
question of what happens when we change
from television is the primary mode of
communication to on-demand programming
and the internet and so since that time
we've moved from what I'll show you is
sort of the more rosy picture of the
effect of the internet on democracy to a
more apocalyptic view of it and there
are three big questions I think that are
posed by the change in communication
technology for democracy the first is to
what extent does the marketplace of
ideas which has been a cornerstone of
our theory of the First Amendment and
free speech to what extent had the
theory of the marketplace of ideas that
the best test for truth really failed in
the Internet age it's not clear that the
marketplace of ideas was ever either so
free or the best test for truth but
certainly in the Internet age I think
we're finding that it's not but it's not
that more voices is lastly leading to
greater chance for truth
the second is does democracy require
some basic agreement on facts among the
population and some minimal trust in
institutions right which is not to say
that the internet is responsible for all
of that right but it exacerbates both
mistrust and this lack of agreement on
facts and the final point is does a
democracy require some way of defining
the political conversation and community
so which limits it to people in the
country
who are human okay as opposed to for an
intervention into an election foreign
speakers as well as BOTS okay I'll talk
a little bit about BOTS with no offense
to Otto here so as I said there was a
rosy picture of the effect of the
internet on democracy up until certainly
the 2016 election there was the sort of
repeated sort of fawning of praise
particularly on the Obama campaign's
digital campaign geniuses who were able
to crack the code of the internet to
both raise money and to campaign there
was this rise in small Duren of
fundraising so that the Internet enabled
people like Howard Dean and even like
Bernie Sanders to raise all kinds of
small donor money as well there was this
evolution in micro targeting that again
was sort of an element of so the
TaylorMade messaging and mobilization
campaigns of obama and and others and
the idea that with the end of television
ads we might move to a more sort of
small d-- democracy kind of environment
in which different types of candidates
could run that didn't have to have big
war chests because they could enable the
you know YouTube or Twitter or the like
could facilitate different types of
candidacies with didn't have that kind
of money now what's happened since the
2016 election is almost you know uniform
apocalyptic forecasts about about what
the the Internet is doing to democracy
well what are those sort of realms well
it's the you know idea of course that
the Internet is promoting fake news or
it's this rise in Twitter bots and the
like that allow as I was saying before
communication from machines
impersonating individuals or of course
our friends Vladimir who is you know
representative of the foreign hacking of
the US election and then as well dark
posts on the net that the idea that you
don't even know when you're being
advertised to and and so the identity of
people as being and institutions and
foreign governments is being cloaked in
the anonymity of the Internet right so
we've moved for
so the Liberation Theology the Internet
to this apocalyptic forecast right so
when I analyzed this question I I think
I'm a little bit different than I want
to say that I usually get three
criticisms I should say whenever I give
this talk the first is what you think is
do is actually old the second is what
you think is bad is actually good and
the third is what you think is original
I've written on already and so let me
say there's a lot of people who are
writing about this I'll usually that's
of course with the Stanford professors
where they but but the you know there
there's a lot sort of people analyzing
this question and yes some of the
phenomena no talk about do you have you
know sort of legacy roots and so
something like fake news right we've had
since we've had news right we've had you
know propagandistic outlets monopolistic
media companies that have you know got
us into wars and the like that's not new
and I do want to say that look there are
good things about the internet for
democracy all of those points that I
made pre that we talked about pre 2016
are still true there are things that and
voices that are enabled by the internet
that were silenced in the legacy
institutions that preceded and then like
I said there is there's a lot being
written on this I don't want to pretend
that all of these ideas are original but
again the focus I want to look at is
what is it about this transformation of
the information ecosystem and
telecommunication environment that
uniquely threatens democracy okay and
the first feature of the internet that
has a uniquely damaging effect on
democracy is the velocity of information
transfer so the speed with which you
know Mark Twain is reported as saying
you know that you can that the truth or
that the lie moves halfway around the
world before the truth puts its boots on
turns out you look on the internet it's
quoted as him saying that in 1917 he
happened to be dead by then but but but
you know that's just an example of fake
news about fake news but he you know
there's something to that right which is
that lies travel quite quickly online
and that it's extremely difficult to
counter them now that's an that's
phenomenon we all are familiar with but
it has particular relevance when you're
talking about elections because
elections have a fixed date and a sort
of predictable calendar to them so that
if hypothetically there is a dump of
emails a week or two before an election
right or lies that become pervasive in
that short period of time they are
unable to be corrected in a way that was
maybe true in legacy institutions right
that is exacerbated by this sort of coin
of the realm of political communication
in the Internet age which is viral
communication right the lack of
intermediated lis elite and sometimes
paternalistic and authoritarian
institutions like say the three networks
right but in that world some of the
extremes of the information environment
that we see today were kept out of the
public realm right again it's not to say
that they weren't you know they weren't
manufacturing consent or doing whatever
else in that in that pre-internet age
but what we've replaced it with is a
premium on virality and what that means
is that whatever types of content are
most likely to be forwarded from one
person to another are the types that are
going to often be popular online and
dominate the political conversation and
what are those types of communications
that kind of information the things that
evoke emotion right particularly outrage
anger sometimes love a little bit less
often right but but you know from your
Facebook feeds or Twitter feeds the kind
of information that you are most likely
to click on err that's most likely to be
forwarded to you third is the internet
gives a megaphone to anonymous speakers
which has previously never been given to
them yes we have a long history a proud
history in this country of anonymous
speaking the Federalist Papers after all
right we're published by Publius and in
case you've seen the musical you know
who one of those authors was right you
know so it's Hamilton you know there are
two others there musicals are on the way
but the I'm waiting for John Jay the
musical you know
we'll see but there's a proud tradition
of anonymity when it comes to political
advocacy right it's even protected under
the First Amendment but we've never did
the anonymous speakers have never had
the kind of megaphone that the internet
gives them that produces two phenomena
and one is it enables the kind of
extremists and hate speech that we have
have seen online and that is sort of
facilitated by the internet and and
that's just a broader category of
unaccountable speech right it's about
speech where you do not have to face the
consequences of your actions right and
your your speech
the second is anonymity is what produces
the bot problem so the just to be clear
what we're talking about we talk about
more in the question the answer a right
a bot on Twitter is a you know some of
you probably even create them but but
about the hazards of talking about this
in Silicon Valley or San Francisco is it
a bot is a you know an algorithm or just
some code that either by itself speaks
right sense messages into the cyberspace
or repeats or amplifies other types of
communication we know that 10 to 15
percent of Twitter accounts in the u.s.
are BOTS roughly 40 percent in Russia
are BOTS we know the president has
retweeted BOTS over a hundred times so
they have real effects we can't measure
it right we can measure the amount of
sort of bought activity online but it's
it's you know it is a new feature of
this information ecosystem that replaces
when it's primarily human sponsored
conversation with machine amplification
of it fourth the internet facilitates
your selecting into information
ecosystems that are essentially
predetermined for your political beliefs
now there's a great debate over this
question of what we call homophony right
is it the case that our online lives are
more echo chambers and filter bubbles
than our offline lives right because
frankly it's maybe more likely that you
will confront a Republican I might say
this in the San Francisco right
on your Facebook feed then you will 5
miles west of here right and so one of
the things about homophony your echo
chambers is that we you know we're
becoming politically segregated in so
many aspects of our life that it's not
clear that the Internet that at least
our Facebook feeds and social media
feeds are actually that much more
politically politically segregated but
they probably exacerbate the political
segregation and polarization that we're
seeing in the larger culture if this
question that I've already alluded to
which is the the sovereignty of sort of
the the ability to regulate the
political communication environment of a
democracy right so a country
historically has been we look with the
u.s. as a proud tradition of intervening
in all kinds of countries elections it's
not like this is the first time this has
happened
however the web is worldwide after all
and because of the anonymity on the
Internet it facilitates the ability of
cross national or non-state actors or
state actors to have an influence on
other countries democracies finally
there's this question of monopoly and
while it's true that we had three
broadcast networks that basically have
monopolies they were treated in some
ways as public carriers and like the
role of Google and Facebook is
qualitatively different than those
monopolies of yesteryear because of the
amount of advertising that goes through
them because of the ability of those
firms to have such a determinative
effect on the political communication I
think that they're in a different
position so much so that their Terms of
Service
their community guidelines are in many
ways the sort of new First Amendment of
our age because or I should say that
they're determining the the first of the
bounds of the First Amendment when I do
teach when I teach First Amendment law I
put up the YouTube or the Twitter
community guidelines and all of them are
unconstitutional if they were if they
were enacted by the state now that's not
actually such a bad thing in some ways
might be because our First Amendment law
is at such an extreme internationally
speaking but these you know whether it's
rules against obscenity or against they
may they ban you know advertisement of
gun
and drugs pharmaceuticals actually
probably illegal drugs too as well as
incitement hate speech and the like
there's all kinds of rules that these
private companies have naturally that
would be unconstitutional if the
government passed them the question is
really where do we go from here
where's for the platforms go where
should the government go and there are
three basic sources of reform the first
is the government right and we can see
that the US government with the
exception maybe of the limited area of
campaign finance disclosure doesn't seem
to be acting to regulate a political
communication online leave net
neutrality out of it for just a second
European governments though are rushing
to fill the void that the u.s. is
leaving and so Germany passed its fake
news bill to make basically find the
internet companies the the large
Internet companies 50 million euros for
every illegal speech act that occurs on
their platform right and you know we'll
see how that plays out secondly there's
platform self-regulation which is where
I spend a lot of my time sort of
thinking about this and that's you know
are the platforms going to add to those
other categories of speech regulation
that I mentioned before with new rules
with respect to fake news or hate speech
and they have rules on hate speech
already and the like and they have been
moving since the 2016 election quite
nimbly I think even if not as far as I
would like them to do to try to address
some of these Democratic pathologies and
the final area of self help right some
of you are developers and in the room
right that they and we have a project at
Stanford where we're trying to develop
more of this technology what tools can
users have in order to combat things
like fake news like hate speech like you
know like echo chambers and the like
right or to combat BOTS so that you know
that an account is is about as opposed
to a human now
in when it comes to these three
different actors the state the platforms
and self-help they're really sort of
seven categories of reform where we're
gonna see some actions they all happen
to begin with D that that's almost
inadvertent I don't want to be sort of
in a kind of Tony Robbins box by
suggesting that that this is like my 70s
to you know solve your life problems but
but but here right here they sort of
general areas of reform and then we have
some concluding thoughts and we can open
it up the first is as I've mentioned
before deletion right so the the
Internet companies the portals have all
kinds of rules Terms of Service
community guidelines and the like about
some content that's simply not allowed
part of the question now is well is
there are there other additional types
of content you know falsehoods and the
like may be more aggressive monitoring
of hate speech that should be deleted
from online the second where Facebook in
particular has been particularly
aggressive is on the area of disclosure
right trying to give you more
information about the speakers and about
the content so that for example they
have now have these fake news flags for
news that has been disputed by fact
checkers right on have you seen those
fake news flags I put it up at the
beginning um you don't see them all that
often one of the are neurotic things is
that if you do you're actually more
likely to engage with the story it's
like it's like oh my gosh here's
something false if it's lag probably not
the effect that they wanted the other is
that there's an interesting Yale study
that finds that if they start flagging
some of these stories that the there is
sort of a abnormally high level of
confidence that you have in other things
that are not flagged right so that then
it has sort of those two
counterproductive quality but disclosure
is uh it's been and in the campaign
finance realm they're they're
aggressively moving to try to thwart
government action here to provide for
greater disclosure of spending the third
and and the most likely area when you
think about search engines you think
about news feeds is demotion of content
right making decisions about the quality
of the information and then putting it
lower if it's bad quality
and higher if it's good quality of
course that's fraught with all kinds of
normative value judgments but it's
inevitable right because when no matter
when you put something above something
else you're making a value judgment
about what users and viewers should see
are you going to place a premium on
virality right are you gonna put a
premium on some of the other values that
I said at the beginning or the other
pathologies on the internet for
Cristiano Bharata who's the founder of
Google News has a really interesting
idea about delaying sort of putting in
trip wires on the internet so that if a
story achieves a certain level of
virality we try to at that point put a
stop on it on certain social media
platforms until a human being can look
at it to see whether it's true right not
eliminated from the internet but to just
put in some kind of trip wire for
virality now you those of you working
internet companies know that's you know
that's not a small undertaking right to
basically monitor all of viral
communication online and so you need to
have some threshold at which you know
you'd have to intervene but that's
another reform idea which is out there a
fifth is dilution is there a way of
having more good content out there to to
diminish the significance of bad content
that sounds like a kind of crazy and an
almost impossible idea it's particularly
difficult in the United States where we
don't have the kind of public
broadcasting and public information arms
that the European governments have so
that as much as I bet in this room
there's a pretty high viewership and
listening audience to NPR and PBS in
other countries that would be a much
larger audience whether it's for the BBC
or particularly in the Scandinavian
countries that spend a considerable
amount of money on public broadcasting
and the like and so if you are able
through government efforts to dilute bad
content that's another possibility
sixth distraction and diversion now this
is this again is a sort of more
authoritarian response
Jennifer Penn one of my colleagues in
the communication department at stamp
has done some really sort of
path-breaking work on looking at how the
Chinese government regulates the
internet on the one hand there's this
walled garden idea that they're you know
they're sensors right there's all kinds
of information and communication that's
censored online um one of the other
things that they do is they have
literally a million person army that's
monitoring what's being said online and
that sort of guides conversations away
from controversial topics so if tienamin
square is the topic of discussion you
sort of have people to come in and they
pollute hashtags on particular types of
issues they may guide conversations in
another direction you might think
hypothetically if you know a leader
wanted to distract from a bad news story
one way to do that is to start maybe
using Twitter in a way that would
distract to another controversy
hypothetically
the last is deterrence and so the I
never next Tuesday I've been invited to
a conference I never thought I'd be
invited to as an election law guy which
is I'm speaking at the NATO psyops
conference so I was like alright that's
when I want to do it right and and I
thought it was gonna like Luxembourg and
Brussels it's in Tampa okay so so it's
like it looks glamorous but alright so
so I'm upset I'm a law professors gun is
speaking NATO great in Tampa and so but
but part of the question there is how do
you deter and cyber activity
particularly when it comes to polluting
the information environment prior to an
election right and it's a tricky problem
of course with our First Amendment but
there are ways that that that one can do
it I mean through classic deterrence
techniques you may seem that we are you
know forcing for example RT Russia today
and Sputnik to register as foreign
agents in a sense Google and Facebook
essentially punished websites that were
putting up fake news and in order to get
money through their ad platforms and
like so there all kinds of deterrent
keep in tech it's still the the there
are still lingering questions though I
think about our capacity to deal with
some of these problems especially if
we're going to keep the kind of First
Amendment
that is really unique to the United
States as I said error implied in some
ways it's the most it's democratic
features of the internet that are
threatening the democracy it is the fact
that viral communication unmediated
communication is leading to these
problems right that that is the the
bedrock problem that we're confronting
in trying to deal with the Democratic
pathologies of the internet secondly
it's hard to think unless we point to
the new information intermediaries as
being Google and Facebook in these
companies it's hard to think who else
fills historic voids of the kinds of
elite institutions that have kind of put
bounds on the permissible conversation
that precedes an election right and it's
never really been the case that
for-profit companies of this magnitude
have had that particular role we could
debate about that but that you know
there are certain intermediary
institutions whether you're talking
about labor unions or political parties
and the like that simply don't have the
power anymore to to guide political
conversation ways that they did
previously and then finally there are
really three models out there as to what
the sort of future of regulating speech
online is going to be is particularly in
the political realm I talked about the
Chinese model right and that is
obviously not that's a tradition that we
want to emulate in the US you see what's
happening in Europe right which is
they're trying to sort of split the baby
here and try in getting some kind of
liability for these companies trying to
regulate speech online and then we have
the United States which is really out on
a limb when it comes to the First
Amendment every area of our First
Amendment law whether it's hate speech
or libel or pornography and the like is
really extreme by international
standards when it comes to freedom of
expression
um are we gonna be sacrificing that
right is it gonna be done by government
is it gonna be done by the private
companies and so if the question that I
started with is right can democracy
survive the internet you know the
clickbait the answer is the answer may
surprise you
I think the the jury is out our
democracy is gonna have to adapt to the
Internet in ways that right now we don't
thank you Thank You Nate that's
fantastic so Rio is gonna be walking
around with the mic please get her
attention I got a couple questions to
start you off with but thank you
and again seriously thank you for making
the time in the midst of this busy time
for you so my big takeaway is that
there's a direct line from Hamilton to
these BOTS
that's fascinating right definitely the
anonymous well I think there's a
franchisor there's a there's a series in
that so one of the things that before we
open up to some some other subjects what
when when you look at the other
international solutions and you touched
on it a bit there you know is there a
great solution but it's just but we're
just the disposition of Americans is it
means we're never going to do it or do
you have ads on any of these novel
approaches to us that that that could
have some some chance of getting
implemented here one of the reasons I
spend a lot of time trying to talk to
the people of the platforms about this
is because I think that they're going to
be the they're gonna make the decisions
I don't think that the government's are
quick enough and nimble enough and sort
of accurate enough in their laws to
really put in the framework that is is
necessary here and let me give you an
example in this even in the area of
campaign finance where I think it's
actually the lowest hanging fruit that
we should be able to force campaign
finance disclosure online for example
there's currently a law the the proposal
the Warner clover char law which would
try to deal with this problem of
foreigns election spending in the US as
well as you know sort of anonymous
spending by by taking the you know the
TV rules and then putting them online
one part of that law says and you know
we need to we need to figure out we need
to get a library up there of all the ads
you know so you know that that that you
know
a particular campaign is presenting some
message it to you but a different
message to you we know that and it's
disclosed and we gotta have the
targeting information who are they going
after demographically like seems like a
very sensible position I'm in favor of
it then when you start talking to the
the folks at the platforms that say you
know what
right now targeting it's like sure
there's some times when you want to say
you know white suburban women between
the ages of 30 and 40 but right now
you're gonna be able to do individual
level targeting where campaigns are
basically giving email addresses to
people so that then you're gonna end up
with you know individual level targeting
for you're not going to publicize that
the individual names of people who were
targeted and same with the actual ads
themselves so that this is true the
Trump campaign they were in a hundred
thousand different variations on ads
right some of which they don't even know
they ran right and so and so you're
gonna develop you have to figure out a
kind of way of having a library of these
ads which is different than say in the
legacy institutions so I think that you
know they're going to be making these
determinations and the technology is
moving so fast that we needed now they
need to be pushed along in some ways
Europe is gonna be the tail that wags
the dog here you know and we'll see if
they sort of respond to these sort of
overreaches by European governments in
ways that will then be salutary even for
our democracy I should say and Europe of
course is not only long you look you
look at South Korea they took down their
Federal Election Commission took down a
hundred thousand Facebook posts not even
Acts pay posts because of the rule on
banning election communication
approximate to an election in in France
in the lead-up to the election where
there was this big dump of emails on
McCrone 48 hours before the election
which violated which prevented political
conversation about it that the law in
France said that you cannot have
basically campaigning in to 48 hours
before an election Facebook then had to
figure a way to block out the email dump
on McCrone in France but then allowed
everyone else around the world to see it
right it's like yeah and so there's just
you know series of things like
happening around the world well and and
that's an interesting point the we had a
talk actually in our first year here
Peter Schwartz on our board thinking
about the future of the internet and one
of the things that he saw was more local
versions of the in the way China does a
very impressive sort of one but that
actually and that type of thing it makes
you wonder whether a plot for an
emerging from a different culture from a
different governmental situation would
balance out or at least change some of
these dynamics do you right I mean
that's basically what's happened in
China that they replicated a lot of
these internet portals with a domestic
authoritarian flavor to them right and
so you know you you but it takes that
kind of walled garden approach to really
get at this no I'm exaggerating a little
bit right because as you said there's
diversity around the world and you know
you talk to the election people at
Facebook and you know once thanks guys
like you guys let's have you have to
deal with this stuff every month like
every month we have two elections per
week they said that dealing with
worldwide right and they're doing it
mean talk about fake news in the u.s.
it's like when they deal with the Kenyan
election right people are dying as a
result of these rumors that are that are
going online and and you know as much as
I think there there are sort of
accessories in all this they they
understand the issue right if they
didn't you know six months ago they
certainly feel like their backs up
against the wall right now and so you
know but but there are easy solutions
here it's a real difficult technical and
sort of philosophical fix and just one
more before we open up to the questions
let's give a little bit of background on
the gerrymandering side of this real
quick can you start by just explaining
us what a special master is we're
talking about a little bit earlier
explain what your role is and and just
sort of set the frame for folks and you
and is exactly what you've done before a
little bit friend or so I'm under a gag
order so we're all part of this right
now I can't tell you obviously what's
happening in North Carolina I've been a
special master a few times I've been a
court-appointed expert to help courts
that with solving the district
controversies you know I've got I got a
nice special master placard it hasn't
helped me at home at all but but but my
kids still don't listen to me but but so
what I'm in what I'm empowered to do
right now as I have in Connecticut and
and Maryland and Georgia in New York
twice for Congress is that I'm appointed
by the court as a nonpartisan expert to
resolve the redistricting controversy by
promoting and and drawing my own plan
and then having basically everybody in
the state hate me for it and then and
then the court then adopts it or makes
changes to it and then everyone will
hate you at least a little bit right
even if you think maybe you know what's
always amazing I can tell you lots of
stories is how sometimes the people you
don't expect to hate you end up hating
you you know but that's why I'm here in
California and doing a North Carolina
redistricting all right we've got our
first question
my main question I guess it has to do
with the First Amendment in foreign
powers and you mentioned how much
protections the foreign or the First
Amendment gives communication here in
the United States but could you do could
you have something like FISA that
basically just gives no free speech to
foreign agents this is a really tricky
question something I and Mike McFaul
who's former ambassador of Russia who's
head of FSI at Stanford we're really
trying to think through this so there is
a really open question as to how much
sort of first the First Amendment
transcends our borders to some extent
you can certainly be I'll give you an
example of campaign finance realm you're
allowed to ban foreigners from spending
any money in connection with the federal
election so you guys we can't do that in
the United States so the First Amendment
means something different what applies
not just to foreign governments not just
to foreign corporations but to foreign
individuals right so there is a
different First Amendment when it comes
to foreigners and so we will try and
there are with and if you see what
they're trying to do with Russia today
and Sputnik there are unique regulations
that can go after so
these foreign agents of governments but
the Internet is a is a anarchic place
right and so it's becoming increasingly
difficult to figure out really who is
behind particular types of speech and
especially when you sort of dealing with
the corporate environment you know where
you don't really know the identity of
the speaker you know is it a domestic is
it a foreign speaker what do we do with
trolls what do we do with bots that are
BOTS could be where is a bot located
right you could have someone in the
United States that is basically having
one of these bot farms that's retweeting
foreign content and like so this whole
sort of jurisdictional element becomes
really complicating the Internet age
another one over here hey so it feels
like a really big problem is just that
Facebook has a newsfeed at all like it's
not just posts that people are sharing
but it's also that they have this sort
of section of their page that says
newsfeed and they're not a news
organization and they don't have
journalists and it really is just sort
of an example of how Facebook is trying
to become the Internet yeah and the
source of all information for a lot of
people that is the only source of
information for their news so you know I
I'm interested in like how do we go
forward especially when you're talking
to these companies that have a vested
interest in being sort of the entire
Internet and there's just a few
companies and then we have actual
journalists that are losing their jobs
across the country and we don't have an
actual journalism taking place so this
is a great question and let me tell you
what I think the problem is with
Facebook okay and one that they
recognized which is that and it goes
back to this small D democratization of
information the thing what you can and
you put you're gonna sort of nail on the
head there or hit the nail on the head
which is that the news feed really isn't
about news right and so what Facebook
does is it organizes all communication
in the same way so that whether it is a
you know a video of your son's
graduation or a Kim Kardashian promotion
or a article from Breitbart or an op-ed
for the New York Times or just a
communication from your friend
it's basically organized in all of the
same ways right so we don't have any of
the cues the information cues that we
have in the offline world replicated in
the online world so that if you go up to
a supermarket checkout counter right and
you see a publication as you approach
the register that says you know for
example Hillary Clinton part of satanic
cult in Washington in a pizza joint
right you are probably going to discount
that you probably just kind of no matter
what but you certainly aren't discount
as you go toward the cash register
because you know what the National
Enquirer the Weekly World News and like
are right but when it's organized in
front of you in your facebook newsfeed
alongside every other kind of
information that you have right it
doesn't have some of the same triggers
and signals that you would have in the
offline world and so that's one of the
so what they need to do is try to figure
out ways to develop those information
queues now one way that they've tried to
do this and then it directly answers
your question is that they're doing an
experiment right now that's they've done
in Sri Lanka and four other countries
where they tried to take the news out of
the news feed I don't know if you've
heard about this right so they said all
right let's take the actual journalism
take it from the news feed and put it in
a separate news the journalist in that
country the media organizations lost 40
percent of their traffic right and it's
like the best of all intentions I think
right but but because the media
environment in these countries has
adapted to Facebook and Google being the
main pipes to which they're going to end
up being you know getting the news right
and so you know again they're damned if
they do damned if they don't and the
question is how can we maybe sort of
Drive in the right direction so jump
excuse me jumping off of that I have an
abstract question that needs two quick
examples so I'm gonna keep the super
brief one is if you look back in media
theory Orson Welles with War of the
Worlds helped do this weird form of
Education for the world that a news
anchor wasn't what you thought it was by
causing mass panic effectively but on a
benign topic right right and the second
example is that in trying to do a credit
of an accredited investor laws to
prevent people of low income from being
Windell out of lots of money because of
fraudulent investments effectively the
government prevented the middle class
from getting in on some of the most
profitable investments of the 20th and
21st century so this seems to me and
here's the abstract question there's
always this choice between whether you
try to structurally prevent some of the
worst abuses that new changes in the
landscape allow very legislation or
whether you try to educate the entire
population as to here's how the people
are going to screw you now in a way they
didn't before how do you think about
this trade-offs you don't either over
regulate or try to over teach yeah so
let me start with the education point so
Sam Weinberg who is a professor Stanford
has directed this whole study on whether
undergraduates high school students can
tell the difference between fake and
real news right and he finds that no
they can't find tell the difference
truth is neither can most adults and so
and so he's trying to develop a
curriculum to try to sort of educate but
but this is no small potatoes here right
you're basically talking about teaching
critical thinking this is not a new
problem right and so we you know and as
you sort of implied there's always this
challenge as to sort of who guards the
Guardians here who's going to be the
educator who's going to decide what what
qualifies as good information bad
information and this is when you you
know the platforms are repeatedly in
this bind in some ways I mean you know
faith the cloud that hung over Facebook
prior to the election was the editing of
the trending news topic that they were
they had human editors we were then
accused of bias against conservative
news outlets right and so you know there
was so then they replaced it with with
they took the humans out of the process
and now we have them being faulted for
what's happening with their algorithms
so I think you're right that is that is
in some ways the big question and it's
it's not a unique question to the
Internet age but you know we are dealing
with I think unique problems now that
require a different kind of solution hi
um first I want to say hi to Renee who I
just now met on Twitter through friends
hi Renee
can we parent yeah Rene will be speaking
in in April thank you let's go know when
you're speaking how do you take
advantage of him thank you my question
is I want to focus on journalists I work
in media and policy communications and
one of the things that was really
apparent throughout this campaign was
the degree to which trusted news sources
really failed to do their job and the
example just from today where the
Washington Post actually caught someone
trying to feed them fake news that
that's how it is supposed to work you're
supposed to have editors and journalists
who vet their sources who check the
veracity of stories who makes sure that
they're not spreading this information
to their readers those are their brands
and my question is you know without
getting into the fact that yes Craig
when he created Craigslist started the
media on a long slow slide to a huge
challenge in their business model we put
that aside for a second how much can we
hold journalists you know and what do we
do to sort of prop up journalism because
there are trusted sources I kind of want
to push back a little on the notion that
just because somebody saw it on Facebook
they're gonna be more prone to believe
it I mean people do put varying degrees
of trust in different institutions can
you talk a little bit about what we can
do to sort of bring journalism back to
the center of this core role I mean cuz
that's really what you're talking about
has failed here yeah it is so part of
the challenge here is that it's very
difficult in the Internet age to find
huah journalists is and what is news
right for the reasons I was saying
before and so you know because
information is coming so is the Drudge
Report journalism right I'm you know is
Breitbart is Huffington Post is you know
pick your we are your friends right the
bloggers and like our academics who are
putting enough and so that's that's a
particularly challenging question and
it's challenging all cross across many
different legal domains because you're
gonna have to figure out some way if
we're talking about regulating the media
right or even propping up media who is
it we're talking about right and so you
know this is a very difficult question
and so then you know Facebook has these
efforts right now
you probably know to sponsor local
journalism to really juice it up
the foundations are coming in and Google
I all of the platforms have something to
do with this there are other ways we
could think about making journalism a
little bit more profitable again because
of course as you know the platforms are
basically destroying the advertising a
business model of these legacy
publications and so one thing that's
been floated is to essentially make them
501 C 3 organizations so that you could
if you contribute to them and in
interesting the New York Times now
hasn't affiliated 501 C 3 and they're
places like ProPublica right that are
trying to do this so that's one way you
could try to beef up the for-profit
model but it's it's hard if you go into
the Washington Post building as I have
before in the journalism room literally
hovering over the journalists is a
screen about four times the size of auto
here right with the traffic on the
website in numbers in real-time so that
you know how much traffic the Washington
Post website is getting at any given
second of the day
right if that's the environment we're
living in right and then it's not
washington post right it's like you know
what do we do to change that another
request right here at the bar what about
traceability or citations are there
discussions of this where you would cite
the article that cites the article it's
like the original article now I come
from from science so I know you can
always find something to support any
position you want but sometimes it's
maybe I recognized you know high-quality
journalists and it's a local teacher
yeah and Facebook trying to do that
they're trying to show the origin there
there are methods that they're adopting
to try to go after that now you know
it's a pretty elite group of people who
are gonna do that kind of investigation
and you know look I don't think the most
of the fake news stories had any effect
on the election right I don't think like
the Pope endorses Donald Trump you know
it's like oh my god well I was in
equipoise before but oh well the Pope
endorsed Donald Trump so therefore you
know I'm voting right and so it's a real
question as to whether fake news had any
effect right but there's no question
that there's widespread false beliefs
out there
and that the internet echo chambers I
mean the pizza gate scandal being that
kind of classic example of this as to
how certain types of rumors that then
have real-world effects but that that
kind that that falls into my disclosure
bubble right our bucket as to what kinds
of techniques we can use in order to
show the origins of information and the
source and and frankly these these
corporations are doing the platforms are
doing it already
and so I'll give you another example
Facebook has moved in the direction of
downgrading content that is forwarded to
you by a friend where that friend has
not engaged with the content right so
that you might think if virality is a
problem and particularly kind of
clickbait ish Ness and so if I see
something that's just evoking emotion I
was like I just forward it to you right
and I don't actually look at the article
that is then deprioritize in the
algorithm as opposed to something I
actually read and then potentially
evaluate it and then sent you ask you so
so talking about journals I think in
some ways we've seen some really strong
responses in the media of in some ways
like antibodies the some of the current
regime and the fake new stuff that's out
there has brought out the best in some
of the new sources that are out there I
wonder if you have a comment on that and
also if to some extent are you hopeful
at all that the law that that our
democracy will have some spring thinning
based on some of these challenges it
seems like there's some very faulty
arguments made whereas we might have
expected sort of more cleverness from a
different some different approaches to
to infringing on the Constitution but in
some ways because of some of the Twitter
sloppiness of oh the Twitter er in chief
or other or other things are there
potentially some good outcomes where
we've talked a lot about the flouting of
norms and in the short term that's a
real problem
longer term is it possible some norms
will turn into laws in in our legal
system that just been sort of custom
before or are there other aspects that
you see of positive outcomes to to some
of the atmosphere there's been so that's
obviously a larger question
beyond the internet the irony of course
is if you're looking for hope it's
coming from the most undemocratic
institutions namely the courts right and
so you know and that's a slender read on
which to hang your hopes right but not
only because the courts can change and
there's gonna be you know massive
numbers of appointments and the like but
you know if the sort of vicissitudes of
judicial behavior it's not necessarily
always Liberty protecting but of course
you know we've seen the courts being the
fulcrums among which a lot of these
policies are sort of depending now on
journalism yes there's been a
renaissance right of both new and legacy
journalism right BuzzFeed has done some
incredible work on for example on BOTS
right I mean I learned stuff from their
inbox and foreign intervention and you
know legis games you look at the
Atlantic is done incredible organ of
course New York Times in Washington Post
did you know in there so that's this
great story about Maggie Haberman
writing literally writing an article
while she is watching her sort of
daughter's you know third grade
performance or something right till I
get certain appeal it's surprising you
know it's like some some incredibly
because they're I mean imagine what it's
like to be one of these people one of
those gentlemen side have some of them
come to my class you think the bags on
my eyes are dark it's like they're
working 24 hours a day they can never
expect and and some real gumshoe stuff
like the the Trump charity stuff I think
we've got another gun right there hi so
I'm assuming that most people here can
remember a time when we weren't entirely
dependent on the internet but the same
can't necessarily be said for the people
you know the kids that are growing up
today so um with that in mind do you
think that it's necessary or appropriate
to engage the younger generations in the
conversation about sort of like this
disparity of opinions and authenticity
that exists on the Internet
you know I don't know what that looks
like whether it's systemic or what it's
kind of a dovetail off of that education
question earlier but what is your
thought on that yeah well I think it's
absolutely critical
because for example right if the problem
is Facebook then you're like young
people are not using Facebook right and
so for the most part no offense to the
Facebook employees in the room but but
you know so but better use an Instagram
so you know you can you can buy another
company and so and so you know or
snapchat right it's really there's some
really interesting work being done about
how the Russians used some of these
other platforms and how images then
amines were then sort of polluting these
other platforms so yes I think it's
absolute critical and we have cast as
the Center for Advanced selling
behavioral science they've the whole
project called the ijen project which is
all about people who've only grown up
knowing the Internet right and how what
are they how do they behave how do they
communicate how do they have
relationships online right all that kind
of stuff and and your first ammendment
class is - is it - undergraduate sir
yeah and so I think you both but but
yeah so I get undergrads to take my
first I teach an undergraduate First
Amendment class and they educate me
right about some of these technology
issues especially example you have some
of the techies who will will come and
take it it's really you know I open is
there an anecdote or anything
particularly jumps out at you that
you've learned there or that surprised
you about their attitudes either and on
the positive or the negative from that
you heard back from your class well one
of my former students is ty Montgomery
who currently plays with the Green Bay
Packers which I'd say I used to teach at
Columbia that never happened to me there
right so that's only happens at Stanford
but you know what thinking about what
they should have think about you know
they they are very familiar they all
have stories right about how rumors have
spread and how you know reputations that
get destroyed and so they they know but
they also it's been amazing to me that
sometimes and this happened with one of
my students was live blogging my class
and then when I called her out on it
like not mad aggressive when I said you
know for those of you live blogging and
she thought I was like invading her
private Internet at that point you know
it's like you know some extent they
don't quite get the fact that you know
we can see all of these things then
they're there for perpetuity hey thanks
I we're not reading your concluding
question questions might you know my
mind goes in a direction I want to see
if it's kind of what where you're going
to in that I definitely agree Democratic
that the Democratic character of the
internet the Internet itself right
threatens democracy as we know it right
and I would also say that the nature of
the Internet and how it works and many
of its institutions threatened
sovereignty as we know it national
sovereignty as we know it and then many
of the institutions that you're working
with are inherently transnational
institutions corporations Facebook etc
and so those and you said yourself that
in fact those are the institutions now
that are interpreting the First
Amendment they're transnational
institutions and so your last question
to the audience so to speak is Europe or
China or the United States or is it
really a transnational institution
that's the wave of the future and as you
know the Internet you know making
sovereignty obsolete and as democracy
depend on sovereignty or not no that's
right and that's one of my first
questions right to what extent do you
need a organizing structure you know a
domestic organizing structure in order
to organize political conversation for
the democracy and I think that the
transnational character of both these
companies and the Internet in general is
what's really threatening that take a
step back we've got one of your a book
that you've edited in the back let's
just speak first I can read that I think
could you just tell us what what that is
let people know what it is and and
you're gonna oh yeah well is it relevant
anymore is it well this is the problem
you know I've been writing this book on
democracy on democracy in the internet
now for I started work at some of this
proposal now three years ago and the
topic of the book has changed 180
degrees right you know because what
we're saying we have this kind of
euphoric and an optimistic view of the
Internet now it's completely changed and
one of the areas that sort of
contributed to this was what was in that
earlier book which came out this was a
Hewlett Foundation sponsored project on
trying to solve polarization right
get the smartest because my political
science friends who smarter than I am to
propose to sort of put their money where
their mouth is and propose solutions to
political polarization now the
polarization as that we saw a year and a
half ago and this was published I it's
completely different than the
polarization that we're talking about
now I mean it's just that order of
magnitude it's not just order of
magnitude it's just a different kind of
polarization and when you talk about the
culture and obviously what's happening
the trouble administration but this is a
these are the top political scientists
who study polarization each proposing
some kind of solution to polarization
that we see at the elite and math level
and that's that's the book we have back
here and and he'll be able to sign them
laughter so I think we've got one more
question for the audience then Nate's
gonna be sticking around so we can keep
the conversation going afterwards we'd
love for you to stick around yes one of
the founders of the Electronic Frontier
Foundation John Gilmore has famously
said that the internet perceived
censorship is damage and routes around
it what would you say to this kind of a
moral a most Nietzschean position that
sees these developments is not good or
bad but inevitable adaptations the
Internet perceives censorship is damaged
and routes around it ah well that's to
some extent that is true except in you
know but it's not which is to say that
that you know obviously check China is
an example in the other direction right
and and the Chinese are not able to do I
mean they've been figured out a way to
wall off that garden but you know
there's censorship in the kind of
deletion that's why I put up all those
different strategies right because
there's deletion of content and yeah
look you're able to usually the you know
if you were an enterprising French voter
and you wanted to figure out a way to
get the McCrone email dump in the 48
hours before the election a lot of the
hackers in this room could figure a way
to do that but most people in France did
not see that stuff wasn't coming over
their Facebook beat and so you know
there there are
examples of where this kind of
censorship in an electoral context
actually works but again part of the
question is not about deletion of
content or prohibiting you from seeing
it's about how its organized before you
what values go into that organization as
what you're gonna see at the top and
what you're gonna see at the bottom and
just before we let you go - go back - to
gerrymandering for Wednesday we were
talking a little bit I wanted to just
draw you out a little bit on the the
class that Utah so which is which is an
interesting for those who don't know so
you taught a class about districting and
when you were at Columbia you want to
tell a little bit about how that worked
in and and what the outcomes of it were
so one of the interesting things about
people there are very few people who
work in this area that's why I've gotten
some of these jobs especially for courts
actually the first time I got I think I
was 29 years old when I did the New York
congressional redistricting and the
reason I did it is because everybody
else in the country was conflicted out
who did this right and so that's how I
started working up the courts and I
don't work the political parties I've
just worked out for courts in doing
these redistricting things and so at
Columbia I developed draw Congress org
where we had the students develop
nonpartisan plans for all the 50 states
just so they could develop the skills
and then so that there could be kind of
benchmark non partisan plans that were
out there that you could then judge the
partisan plans against and and those are
actively being used today for being
actively ignored by but you know they
but the consequence of it right was that
the media at least we had something what
was possible like if you say you can't
draw a district this way well actually
there's you know a 24 year old student
at Columbia who's figured out a way to
do that yeah well I know that there
continue to be a ton of questions and we
want to get to more of them thank you so
much for opening yourself up to this big
question time here it's like the British
government here for a second
please give Nate a big round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]